if it looks like yep there it comes
[Applause]
get water check it out
you gotta make them stuff on Lopez could
not get back to Trey your couple hawks
what a ballgame Trey for three pretty
young just came up right here we look
where Lopez is you got to be closer than
that since the start of Zach Lavine
his three ball is good Wow both teams is
suiting the ball tonight Dover on the
handoff Zach Lavine has further on him
it's a screen that deals with the pig
Rock has left gets inside reverse and
scorch acog Oh leave Zach Lavine has 31
Alex went seven second six my second
stray tried to what it
ladies second ago when that ties the
game and just weaves his way through all
those white shirts ox buy five of 220
sack lemonade slaps at home
I mean we are seeing a ballgame tonight
I mean with the crossover Levine gives
it over Paris it back to Zach Jeffrey
defending but Zach Lavine Tyson man he's
got 42 push it up the floor 164 159 Trey
off the glass good
he's got 49 it keeps the Hawks in this
thing with 167 Zach Gornick a lotta
clock gets into the lane throws it up it
in off the glass
timeout Atlanta road blocked screen from
Robin Lopez got the play going and then
it was left to